I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense I really believe that life is
about lessons and the lessons are gonna
keep on coming until we learn them and
the way we know agree completely
literally and sometimes you have to go
completely broke yeah you don't have to
get to that point but sometimes there's
bottoming out the best thing that you
can do and so how'd that happen
you know what happened is I mean that's
why I wrote my latest book right
gametime decision making I made bad
decisions based upon assumptions I
surrounded myself with the wrong people
the wrong ideas but what happened was my
ego I got into a lawsuit with the
neighbor that I bought a condo
conversion from and I spent millions of
dollars of cash proving I was right oh
wow right as a lawyer that's really dumb
but the interesting thing I was really
happy you made a ton of money oh they
all did you lost a lot but I always was
lawyers get paid no matter what exactly
right and remember that they're gonna
get divorced too which I have not gone
oh well I do but divorce lawyers
especially what was interesting for me
though is that I literally always felt
like I had at least forty to fifty
million dollars I could fall back on
because I owned thirty three properties
I had a ski mountain a golf course with
tons of equity but because I was so
arrogant I never asked for help right
it's a lesson that I've learned but I
went to my private bank and I said hey I
need another five million and they said
hey great where are you gonna get it I
said I'm just gonna refinance this
property I'll take a line no you won't
I'm like what do you mean that one I got
like 40 million or 50 million dollars in
equity you're not gonna give me five
million I've been a good customer at the
bank they're like well we're kind of
going under ourselves we'd rather hold
your property then extend credit to
anyone else we're just not extending
credit on property anymore we're nearly
not sure about the valuations you know
it's too high of a risk for us at this
time go somewhere else that's when the
lessons started coming right because I
still had cash needs and things were
moving quickly word gets out you're
looking for money and the properties
can't be evaluated fast enough because
they're having problems cuz everyone's
moving and before you needed a pulse to
get alone now I was like state state
income we can't really look at stated
income right you know well your salary
is not that high at least I'm Berg's
yeah well I didn't need a high salary
right this was
and I have equity of this and so then
you start selling things and they're not
selling fast enough he still bills well
then all of a sudden you miss one
payment then try to get a loan okay so
things over 100 right over a hundred
million dollars in value right on paper
over one hundred million dollars I lost
and I remember the greatest piece in my
life was the day that I literally went
bankrupt but not because of the clean
cleansing of bankrupt I actually didn't
owe anybody any money excited so much
equity it all just worked itself out but
the hardest thing was when I went
bankrupt I had gotten my job based off
of me being a successful business person
to being wealthy and being able to raise
money make money and worsley Steinberg
especially at that time we did article
in Sports Illustrated
he created legacies for athletes 75% of
all football players for example went
bankrupt two and a half years after
playing and here his CEO is bankrupt
how's that gonna look right so I was
terrified telling him I thought I was
gonna lose my job and no warned me who's
not my business partner but him they
both were really supportive but here's
the worst thing and where's where I
found my piece as I was driving home I
realized I had to tell my mom and my mom
was that person who always was doctor
lawyer failure don't take big risks
study hard work hard get a normal job
like my siblings did she said the
internet wasn't gonna work out - right
Yeah right
I had that job offer that made me money
but imagine going to tell your mom who
you think loves you because you bought
her a house in a car who you think loves
you because of your financial success
that was the only thing that
distinguished me from these
extraordinary siblings which really has
an energy signed a five year old story
of like money equals happiness yeah
imagine having to tell her that you went
bankrupt but moreover I realized I
didn't take her house out of my name so
I lost her house oh yeah so I'm crying
holy hallway over to her house oh my god
and I'm in my mind I know whatever saw a
red fox when he used to be like
Elizabeth like remember my mom's Drive
was Jewish guilt
I thought Jewish guilt look like I don't
know it's yes right well he's guilt in
general right it was like okay I'll give
you an example of a parenting
okay I got into a fight with my younger
brother and we're pounding each other on
the floor
and my mom would sit there crying saying
you're hurting right that's your skill
in the class of gray or just telling you
you know doctor any girl be perfect I
think a skill you know like maybe the
Catholics Catholics invented it and Jews
perfected in one way or another but it's
there in this you know but I literally
thought like she was going it was gonna
break my heart in hers yeah and so I
went on told her that I had lost
everything and including her house and
she would have to move and without
blinking without crying without any
guilt she looked at me and asked me if I
was okay if she could help me give me
any money I was like how could she be he
was like the mom that i sat there
telling how you know you're such a loser
there was the person that like set forth
that trajectory in my life and I looked
at her and I was already on the
spiritual path and I said that's what
the truth looks like
you